bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence ensuite avec le sommaire
développer sa fibre artistique pendant
les vacances c'est ce que propose le
prisme des stages de théâtre et de danse
se sont organisés pour les enfants c'est
nikos ans la directrice du prisme nous
les présentera en plateau à guyancourt
le visiteur est invité à découvrir les
tableaux de bertrand perron l'artiste
travaille sur des plaques d'acier qu'il
fait roudier il en ressort des oeuvres
corrosive
vous les découvrirez enfin dans notre
rendez vous dédié aux plus jeunes il
sera question de cinéma michael et demi
d'euros nous parlera dessinée petit déj
de montigny-le-bretonneux et nous
présentera celui de ce dimanche
le film d'animation à nina sera diffusé
à la salle jacques brel à noter dès
maintenant pour demain à versailles un
concert de musique classique au profit
de france avc est organisée dans le
temple de la ville à 20h30
accessible en entrée libre le but du
concert et de recueillir les dons des
spectateurs
ils serviront à soutenir le projet bus
avc un bus qui sillonnera les routes des
yvelines au mois de novembre pour
informer les habitants en écoute
marraine coquillaud la responsable de
l'antenne 78 nous en dire plus elle
était au micro de mélanie poké le bus
c'est une campagne avec un partenariat
avec l'agencé régionale de la santé
idf et la fédération ile de france
il va y avoir cinq artistes une soprano
soprano mezzo d'une embellie pour c'est
très important et justement la musique
c'est encore mieux parce que la musique
c'est un équilibre pour les gens que
fait leur avc
le théâtre sera à l'honneur ce week end
à saint cyr l'école aujourd'hui jusqu'à
dimanche se tient le festival mort de
rire au théâtre gérard philipe
pour cette troisième édition cinq
troupes amateurs se produiront sur scène
de la pièce de boulevard à la comédie en
passant par molière on écoute ophélie
murray présidente de l'association la
divine comédie
c'est elle qui organise le festival l
est et au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est un festival de théâtre amateur qui
regroupe plusieurs troupes des yvelines
et de la france entière et qui permet de
faire connaître un peu le théâtre et
dans un cadre différent du théâtre
classique on peut apprendre à l'école ou
voilà puis pouvoir promouvoir activités
théâtre dans toutes ses formes et
notamment la comédie sial vendredi soir
on a un premier spectacle le samedi
après midi
on a un spectacle à 14 heures avec une
troupe de jouy du 28
une troupe à 17 heures qui vient de
versailles est une troupe à 21h une
troupe qui nous vient de toulouse est
une troupe lé dimanche à 15 heures pour
un nouveau spectacle à chaque fois c'est
un spectacle différent et une pièce
différente
les vacances de la toussaint débutent ce
mercredi pas toujours évident d'occuper
les enfants quand ils restent à la
maison
le prisme d'elancourt propose de les
initier au théâtre et à la danse des
stages pour laisser libre cours à
l'imagination et à la créativité
sabine concerne la directrice de
l'établissement nous a rejoint en
plateau pour nous en parler bonjour
sabine un jeu alors présenté nous un
petit peu ces vacances créatives deux
ateliers sont proposés à partir de
mercredi prochain
voilà mais tout d'abord au dire aussi
que le prisme ses centres de
développement artistique de saint
quentin en yvelines donc proposé de
créer de jouer et de faire ensemble
pendant les vacances scolaires ça tombe
sous le sens donc voilà ce qu'on a
proposé son des stages en théâtre et en
danse mené par des artistes qui sont
associés à tout le travail que le prisme
fait avec les artistes la diffusion des
spectacles et puis donc les propositions
de développement artistique de ne s'agit
de à gâteau fadel en danse un stage qui
démarrent à partir de mercredi
mercredi prochain trois jours intenses
de travail d'expression corporelle mêler
les arts plastiques avec pour mieux se
représenter se déplacer dans l'espace
faire ensemble comprendre son corps
voilà et puis et puis s'amuser je
voulais prendre du plaisir et fassent
important on danse également et en
théâtre du coup ton à la rentée être
pareil une approche à peu près sur les
mêmes les mêmes critères que ce que je
viens de dire
c'est à dire peut être abordée
l'expression ou l'écriture ou ou là où
la lecture mais c'est essentiellement
passée par le geste passé par le mot
passer par le verbe
voilà un psy des moments intenses y
déjeunent tous ensemble
dis donc on essaie du matin jusqu'à où
je crois qu'on démarre vers les 10
heures du matin je connais pas tous par
coeur il faut aller sur le site monde et
marque à 10 heures du matin et on va
jusqu'à fin 2000 y eu d'après midi et la
voilà il ya quelque chose d'instance qui
se passe et tout ça en relation avec une
artiste qui est le projet du centre de
développement artistique de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors ça ça n'arrive pas à qui ces
ateliers jusqu'à quel âge est ce qu'on
peut participer
alors c'est de 6 à 14 ans globalement ça
sera sur toutes les périodes de vacances
là on va parler on y parle des vacances
d'automne très précisément parce que ça
démarre à partir de mercredi mais on en
aura également en hiver pendant les
vacances de février et les vacances de
printemps et donc sur la période en
cours de 6 à 14 ans ça il faut bien
regarder les tranches d'âge pour la
danse des tranches d'âge pour le théâtre
il ya deux tranches d'âge pour le
théâtre et les artistes y faire et alors
vous le disiez les enfants sont encadrés
par des artistes en résidence au prisme
notamment le collectif de simone que
nous avons rencontrés est ce que vous
pourriez nous les représenter un petit
peu qu'ils sont quel est ce collectif
qui sont ces filles c'est très important
parce que le prisme est aussi engagée
pour 51 en yvelines avec d'autres datent
d'ailleurs dans une démarche beaucoup
plus d'équité entre hommes et femmes
donc de soutenir la production féminine
d'un spectacle vivant et le collectif
des filles de simone en fait partie
complètement donc c'est des gens que je
connaissais déjà parce qu'ils ont
travaillé avec pierre joxe était un
artiste associé au programme là dessus
elle avait un projet leçon venu m'en
parler et je les ai soutenus y compris
le réseau créative et donc on a avancé
dans leur spectacle c'est un peu
compliqué d'être l'origine du monde
et puis voilà elles ont aussi une
attention aux autres ce que je voulais
dire aussi c'est que ces artistes qui
sont choisis les filles de simone dont
elles sont trois et fille de simone
comme agathe fadel ou autres sont des
artistes qui sont ouverts aux autres qui
se nourrissent dans la transmission
qu'il donne dans leur stage dans leur
atelier c'est pas le cas de tous les
artistes et ils ont bien le droit de
vouloir travailler dans leur atelier de
n'être qu'entre mais là il ya des
artistes qui ont besoin de s'inspirer de
se ressourcer de se jauger de ce décès
steam et et donc il ya un vrai un vrai
partage entre je donne je reçois voilà
un père du petit mot sur pour ceux qui
ont peut-être loupé ce coup ci il est
également possible de s'inscrire pour
les vacances d'hiver
et de prendre tout à fait donc la
meilleure des choses est d'aller sur le
site sinon vous faites 01 30 51 75 50 et
on doit être capable de vous deux vous
réponds vérifier quand même le numéro de
téléphone parce que j'ai pas tout révisé
avant de venir
voilà mais je crois qu'il reste encore
des places 1 on peut parce que c'est
quand même des groupes qui sont limités
à 10 12
donc je pense que là il ya encore
quelques places pour quelques personnes
qui voudraient parfait mais le message
est passé à nos téléspectateurs 30
secondes pouvaient dire qu'on fait aussi
des choses pour les parents et les
enfants papariga l'arrivée de débit non
américaines d 1082 voilà un des stages
de danse et des salles de théâtre pour
les parents et les enfants c'est notre
façon de vivre ensemble quelques samedis
par mois également donc du coup c'est à
retrouver sur le site internet vous
pouvez retrouver toutes les informations
en tout cas merci beaucoup sabine
caussade est revenu sur notre plateau
pour nous présenter ces vacances
créatives on le rappelle pour cet
automne les stages commence mercredi et
se termine vendredi prochain merci
beaucoup c'est l'inertie on prend la
direction de guyancourt à présent la
ville propose de découvrir le travail
corrosif de bertrand perron cet artiste
de rambouillet réalise ses oeuvres en
faisant rouillées des plaques de métal
un concept pour le moins original
on vous donne un aperçu de cette
exposition
abstraction corrosive c'est en ces
termes que bertrand perron définit son
travail l'artiste expose actuellement à
l'hôtel de ville de cui en cours
une vingtaine d'oeuvres sont visibles
tout réalisé par la dégradation
ce sont des heures en fait sur plaque
d'acier et ses plaques d'acier en fait
je les fais roulier voilà j'ai fait
rouillé avec de l'eau essentiellement je
peux ajouter le site de pigments dedans
mais c'est essentiellement oui avec de
l'autre un procédé naturel fait
c'est un peu comme des vanités c'est une
idée quand on les regarde on peut se
dire sont comme nous l a dévolu à
vieillir
elles vivent quelque part c'est pas
quelque chose de statique est un travail
sur l'aspect éphémère de la vie menée
depuis 2008
cette réflexion lui est venue en
regardant la rouille qui se formait sur
une voiture j'avais un véhicule ces
vieux en très mauvais état qui rouille
est partout et je trouvais que cette
rouille a aussi été très belle et
intéressante et qui avait quelque chose
à faire avec la cause moi c'est comme ça
que l'idée de travailler avec la cie
ce qui est aussi très intéressant au
travail de bertrand pacé combat que ces
oeuvres évolue vraiment entre les
moments où il décrit les moments où il
est exposé et peut-être même encore
d'ici quelques années on verra encore
des endroits différents et pourtant
c'est toujours la même
tout comme ses oeuvres l'exposition de
bertrand perron est éphémère
elle est à découvrir jusqu'au 26
novembre c'est maintenant l'heure de
votre chronique dédiée aux plus jeunes
aujourd'hui michael almy d'euros et en
plateau avec nous pour nous parler du
ciné petit déj de montigny le bretonneux
bonjour michael pour camille alors
effectivement je vais vous parler de
leurs des rendez vous les plus prisés à
montigny-le-bretonneux le ciné petit déj
qui se tiendra ce dimanche 16 octobre à
la salle jacques brel je vous vois
sourire camille ce n'est pas une blague
dès que les billets sont mis en vente
les familles se jettent dessus les 250
places de jacques brel sont facilement
prise
ils trouvent facilement preneurs
l'algérie maire déléguée à la vie
culturelle à monter votre josé cachin
nous donne les objectifs de ce rendez
vous c'est de donner la possibilité aux
familles l'hymne antenne de se retrouver
un dimanche matin autour d'un moment
très convivial des familles qui en
général ont des enfants qui sont en bas
âge donc ça leur permet de se retrouver
autour d'un petit déjeuner avec des
maquillages qui sont prévues pour les
enfants et puis autour d'une projection
de film qui s'adresse aux plus petits ce
n'est pas une nouveauté michael
puisqu'il ya déjà eu deux éditions voilà
on ne change pas une recette qui
fonctionne les dernières éditions toutes
les deux a programmé cette année on fait
le plein comme je le disais précédemment
l'idée de créer un cinéma petit déj tous
les trimestres à destination des 5 à 8
ans présentation du concept on a un
atelier de maquillage qui est prévue en
bas où les enfants peuvent se maquille
et on a un grand buffet avec un petit
déjeuner
les parents viennent se servir les
enfants viennent se servir ça se passe
sur scène voilà jusqu'au moment où on
invite les gens à s'asseoir avant la
projection du film
donc on est sur un créneau qui est de 10
heures 12 heures
alors nous parler du concept depuis tout
à l'heure mais ce qu'on aimerait savoir
aussi c'est quel film sera projeté
dimanche j'y arrive qui a mis un petit
peu de patience les familles à pourront
voir le film d'animation annie la sortie
en 2013 ce dessin animé a été réalisée
par l'uruguayen alfredo soder git
il raconte l'histoire d'une petite fille
à rêveuse se voyant puni après une
bagarre on regarde un extrait je
m'appelle aline ait aissa là ce nom est
un palindrome il peut se lire dans les
deux sens à l'endroit comme à l'envers
and i know iata il se laisse que des
palindromes on c'est 3 palindrome on
dirait une blague mais alors ça ne te
plaît pas
on
dans mon école il ya des camarades que
j'adore et d'autres qui m'a ce film
n'est pas très connu du grand public et
c'est l'objectif comme nous l'expliquent
josek achats on écoute on est on est
toujours à la recherche de projection
qui sortent des projections qu'on peut
trouver dans les grandes salles de
cinéma l'objectif c'est pas de diffuser
dessin animé pixar ou autre c'est
justement de sensibiliser les plus
jeunes un une catégorie de cinéma qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de voir donc on est
toujours dans une recherche de deux
films qui sont des films un message
thématiques ou autres voilà celui ci ont
fait partie c'est terminé pour cette
chronique j'ai oublié de vous donner le
prix pour assister à ceci les p'tits déj
il faudra débourser 3 euros 90 à par
personne si vous êtes intéressé ne
tardait pas il reste quelques places
vous pouvez le retirer à l'hôtel de
ville ou directement sur le site le jour
j vous allez acheter quelques billets
peut-être camille je sais pas pendant
votre famille où vous allez tous à l'eau
pour moi tout seul là ne me sous-estimer
mickael j'aime beaucoup les films
d'animations en tous cas merci beaucoup
nous a reparlé de ce ciné petit déj on
vous le rappelle c'est ce dimanche à 10
heures à la salle jacques brel
on passe maintenant à l'agenda les
rendez vous à ne pas manquer
après le petit déj
on passe au goûter la mjc de magny les
hameaux prend un peu d'avancé organise
un goûter d'halloween pour les enfants
de 4 à 10 ans déguisement obligatoire
l'après midi est ouverte à tous sur
inscription
mardi soir à coignières les contes de
notre enfance prendront vie sur scène
avec barbet neige et les sept petits
cochons au bois dormant
au programme danse théâtre et humour un
spectacle à découvrir au théâtre
alphonse daudet et je vous propose
d'ailleurs de regarder un extrait on se
quitte en musique je vous retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
du 7-8 loisirs d'ici là très bon
week-end à tous
oh
non